even as a child Tracy Lee stood on this
bridge and watched the trains bound for
London city centre all her life she's
lived on London's outskirts in the
borough of Dagenham it used to be much
nicer cleaner and safer here she says
that always looked after the bridges I
come not falling for that but it's been
the last what five six years that I've
seen this walk could be longer this
bridge d/dt reaiiy
and the rubbish that's been here for
weeks like many regions Dagenham has
been hit by the government's austerity
cuts for many decades car manufacturer
Ford employed many in the area Tracy's
family worked in the industry too then
10 years ago production came almost to a
complete halt now many in Dagenham feel
left behind not so much by Europe but by
their own politicians and the brexit
vote was a welcome opportunity to vent
this frustration the government only got
myself to buy more paper for today out
because if they've been fair not keep my
can always changes and treating others
better than others then I think they all
would have stood it voted him and her
sir I feel as this citizens of brand
kracie likes taking her grandson to the
local museum which tells the area's
history Dagenham zall ways been a
working-class area and its people have
always been progressive early on women
here stood up for equal pay and Tracy
thinks there used to be more solidarity
here
the borough has undergone a radical
change in recent years it seen one of
Britain's largest influxes of immigrants
that's another reason why many year
voted for brexit there are numerous
Eastern European food shops near
Tracey's home many of the sales staff
still feel at home in Dagenham but
others speak of a changed atmosphere you
know there is always you know somewhere
behind you know this you know that
feeling you know that we are immigrants
you know but now some people know they
just Express that's pretty more freely
you know giving up is no option
the people of Dagenham have audacious
plans for revitalizing the area they
want to build a large film studio
Dagenham council leader and labor member
darrenrodgers pushing the initiative he
grew up here he too is from a
working-class home and he says
romanticizing the past won't work what I
want to do is keep those people thinking
outside the box but keep them in the
borough and that's why we're now talking
about films not Fords the plan is to
build a film studio and work spaces for
artists Tracy now works in the new
community center she's good with her
hands man helps artist Chad McHale who
wants to adapt an English fairy tale
into a puppet show well I want them to
enjoy the experience of making to find
out how their hands can be employed in a
way that brings pleasure to other people
things are looking up in Dagenham
London's Mayor Sadiq Khan has come to
see for himself
Darren Rodwell is showing him around
Tracy would like to tell Sonny Khan what
Dagenham needs most urgently but he's
got no time to talk a disappointment for
Tracy and the others but she's pleased
that the local council is stimulating
the area's cultural sector because he
starts oh you are important in Espiral
you are important we are interested it's
nice to bring it here because it's
nothing to bring it to this barrel but
even so it'll be years before these new
projects yield proper jobs
Tracy though is happy that a start has
been made who knows her grandson Jimmy
may grow up to be a famous film director
from da cunha